Apple says many of its most popular
products are vulnerable to hacking and
is urging millions of its users to make
security updates and to do it now the
warning says hackers could gain control
of some devices including its iPhones
Michael George is here with the latest
Michael I was one of many busy making
that update yesterday good morning good
morning a lot of people were doing that
when we usually get that notification
update our phones a lot of us ignore it
but this time experts say don't wait
there's a security loophole that could
let hackers take control of your phone
and the latest update can fix it
Apple users going to the tech Giants
updated page will find easy fix
instructions on what to do next to
prevent a break into their devices but
Apple also explains quote for the
protection of our customers Apple
doesn't disclose discuss or confirm
security issues until an investigation
has occurred and patches or releases are
generally available this is what we call
a zero day vulnerability when it's been
exploited by hacker before the company
in this case Apple have detected it and
been able to do something about it the
affected Apple devices include iPhone 6s
models in later iPad 5th generation and
later iPad Air 2 and all iPad Pro Models
Mac computers running a Monterey
operating system as well as some iPods
so if somebody was to exploit them they
could get onto your phone and sort of
turn on the the microphone or look at
screen screenshot of the phone or
potentially access files Benjamin Reed
at the cyber security firm mandiant sees
Apple's response in a larger context it
shows that companies have got button
very responsive when a vulnerability is
identified being exploited in the wild
they're giving everybody the tools to to
fix that flaw and protect themselves and
what's going on in a world Tethered to
Tech is being seen by some as having a
silver lining this is really a function
of the fact that they're innovating
they're constantly developing and as
much as there are vulnerabilities in our
dependence on technology Security
Experts say the average smartphone user
may not be the real Target it's likely
being used in targeted attacks for
people who are human rights Defenders or
government officials you definitely want
to try to update as quick as you can
so your chances of being hacked are low
these kinds of attacks usually Target
specific individuals by the way just for
an example it took me about 45 minutes
to download and install the new update
on my phone but of course that can vary
depending on your Wi-Fi speed Jeff yeah
Michael thank you very much this was I
mean because I feel like I just updated
recently and then it the warning came in
so and they're saying with this one do
it yeah and mine took a little while
like Michael's too but I have like that
much memory left on the phone as part of
the problem let's see fewer pictures you
got to clear out some of those videos
that Michelle sent yes well you know
you've got to pay attention to those on
vacation so was it was it my time job it
wasn't minding the phone right